nous ouvrons donc cette édition avec un
chiffre le chiffre de cette édition 19
cela fait faisait 19 ans que le Paris
sa-germain n'avait pas remporté le
championnat de première division de
football depuis hier et grâce à ce
succès face à Lyon 1-0 le titre est
acquis pour la capitale mais aussi d'une
certaine manière pour le département des
Yvelines puisque les joueurs s'y
entraînent au Camp des Loges don on ne
sait d'ailleurs pas quand ni où il sera
transféré dans les prochains mois si
vous nous suivez en direct en ce lundi
la célébration du titre va se tenir ce
soir ce sera aux alentours de 18h30 19h
nous en parlerons bien évidemment lors
de la page sport de ce soir pour
l'instant vous avez la parole yvelinois
êtes-vous fier du titre de cette équipe
micro trottoir signé Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude ah c'était normal c'est nous les
premiers c'est nous les leaders
Ibrahimovic c'est le meilleur vive Paris
et c'était comme ça ça devait se passer
comme ça à la Ligue des Champions amp
déjà ils étaient au top c'est une
victoire pour moi vraiment avec tous les
stars qu'il y a normalement il doit
avoir 15 points d'avance et devant
Marseille et Marseille avec ce qu'ils
ont rien du tout ben je suis content
puce que je suis supporter parisien et
j'espère qu'on va gagner encore l'année
prochaine bah V la victoire du PSG tout
le monde est content pariss ont bien
joué on espère que ça va continuer comme
ça et ben ça faisait longtemps
qu'onattendait voilà c'est tout moi je
suis pas un foeux feux mais voilà on
l'attendait on l'attendait et alors il y
a rien à dire rien à dire on est les
champions on est les champions et on est
les champions on sera toujours les
champions vive le
parisgermain voilà le message est clair
au moins pour ces premiers éléments
concernant le titre voilà ce qu'on
pouvait en tout cas dire ce soir